alright guys bangbang I have Julia here
I'm super excited to do this thanks for
agreeing to come on and talk for a while
absolutely I'm excited to be here be fun
alright so we've known each other for a
while
we are investors in the awesome business
that you've built but before we get to
all of that let's start with just
where'd you grow up and kind of how did
you get into health care yeah so
everyone's based in Austin as you said
I'm actually a Texan born and bred so
was born in Dallas spent much of my life
there so obviously my whole youth until
I went to college at Vanderbilt in
Tennessee and then came back to the
North Texas area and then went to Boston
for grad school and then came back so
did move to Austin about four years ago
for the business but ultimately have
always kind of been in a Texas area for
my career and grew up an only child and
I think that's influenced a lot of my
drive and ambition is kind of growing up
in that type of environment and
ultimately didn't have a significant
kind of professional interaction in the
healthcare industry I was really more
after college I went into management
consulting at Deloitte and then I went
to business school it was really
traditional my parents are lawyers it
was much more of a corporate path right
I didn't even know entrepreneurship
could be a career path it'd be a serial
entrepreneur like had never even heard
of any of this and so when I went to
business school I actually got exposed
to entrepreneurship but not to
healthcare and then I kind of had this
five year journey after business school
to think about what kind of company I
would want to start and felt really
called
to entrepreneurship but then ultimately
didn't get into health care until I had
the combination of both wanting to start
a company and then a personal experience
with some really vague medical issues
that
caused me to become really passionate
about the space and of course
specifically about lab testing as we'll
talk about so this it was a it was a
unique journey for me one that I think
when I talk about being in healthcare
sounds a bit like this story where I had
this experience and all of a sudden I
just started this company but really it
was much more thoughtful than that and I
already had looked at what it would take
to be a founder over the years and this
was an idea that I came to and
ultimately had vetted quite well as
something I was gonna teach ants form
this broken area of healthcare but I
obviously was not a likely candidate to
start a highly regulated lab testing
company and certainly had to go through
all of the steps that that would take to
bring this to life yes so I think your
life kind of path there's a lot of
people who are on the same path right
they don't know about opening a business
they've never been exposed to it and
there's almost this desire for the
safety and stability of go work at a big
company or go be a kind of search
professional make a decent living and
have a great family and and you know
live your life and be happy right yeah
what was kind of the thing that pulled
you from that especially since you
didn't have that exposure at a younger
age right I mean it I had really had a
very traditional both where I grew up I
went to a big Texas public high school
it was all Texas high school football
cheerleading everyone went to the
University of Texas or to a large
University and then you picked a career
path after after school and so I
certainly very much fit that bill in
some ways it's just that traditional
path there are other things though that
I now look back realized made me a
little bit different and I think a
couple of them was I was very academic
which was not popular throughout both
high school in college and I was very
academic because I wanted to be not
because of some kind of false pressure
outside pressure I also was an
equestrian so instead of kind of doing
all the sports that everyone else was
doing since I was eight until I was 25 I
was a an amateur level equestrian and
ended up winning several World
Championships and did that at a pre
Olympic level first a couple decades and
so that required both the unique
discipline and resilience that I think
equestrian sports and generally sports
brings to hard work and also for me to
kind of do things off the beaten path I
was by myself it wasn't with my friends
at weather it wasn't with my social kind
of network at school and at college so I
didn't really tie that together at the
time but I think when I was making these
choices later in my life and felt super
called to and driven towards
entrepreneurship when I made a decision
to do this and to walk away from what
others externally view to success it was
actually pretty easy for me and it
wasn't because I'm somehow somehow I
don't care about what other people think
or I'm totally insulated from opinions
and and social constructs but I had been
making decisions throughout my life that
weren't necessarily understood or
popular in the moment because I was
personally fulfilled by them and I had a
really overwhelming internal compass
that I knew at the end of my life if I
didn't try to be a founder and start a
company that I was going to regret it
and I did not tie that to the company
being successful I tied it to starting
the company and trying knowing very well
that it would likely fail and so I think
that that orientation for me was really
helpful I did I had really supportive
networks I had supportive parents a
supportive partner but I will say I mean
my parents were also really worried I
walked away from a VP level job at a
public company to do this and and you
know there they said look you've worked
your entire life you've never taken a
break you've gone from job to job you've
never taken a break like maybe just take
a B and like don't make
that's big decision on this random thing
that we all and everybody else thinks is
a terrible idea
and I did it anyway and and you know for
better or worse I think part of it with
being a founder and making these choices
is if everyone thought it was a good
idea would already be done so you have
to be able to really have that faith
that at least it's worth trying and then
also kind of say okay I appreciate the
feedback but I'm gonna go ahead and do
this and I'm not gonna care too much
about what other people think yeah it's
interesting too because you talked about
not wanting to go start a specific
company but just start a company in
general and then you wouldn't kind of
found the idea maybe explain like what
is that process like look I know that I
want to start a company but I don't
necessarily have an idea of what that
company is yet and already needed to
figure that out well I think it comes
first from identifying or at least what
I did was identify where I really felt
fulfilled at work and I had been at a
number of different organizations all of
which were great organizations but I
felt like five to ten percent of the
employees did 95 percent of the impact
not the work everybody didn't work but
you know there was it was a question of
tying a lot of work and sort of pulling
the Machine forward and driving results
in an organization and my frustration
level around not being able to drive
change was something that I internally
just could not live with and so that
came across organizations across sectors
etc and you start to see it even and
founder CEOs as they scale right and
things get bigger and they can't be in
that same quite that same founder
mentality and I very much saw myself as
being someone who needed to be able to
move at that pace and put in that effort
and see if I could build something and
so that for me was the start and then
from there I spent about four and a half
five years after business school meeting
with classmates friends going through
different industries I looked at
financial services
to payments I looked at travel I looked
at food and there are opportunities in
every industry at any time even now but
what really separated it for me was I
couldn't find that idea that I both felt
was the right time in the market that's
more important than people want to
acknowledge and something passionate
enough about where I could make a
multi-year potentially decade commitment
to and so all of that work had been
underway when I both had the idea for
Everly well that had an investor who
also had a related idea he ended up
being our first angel investor and we
were able to put that together and make
this decision and it didn't I mean to be
clear when I made the choice it was very
hard I really loved my boss and my prior
job and it was very difficult and didn't
feel like it was going to work it was
not something where suddenly this light
came on and all these things that I had
been doing to prep over the last five
years made it an easy decision
it just all these pieces did inform me
being able to make the decision and
actually take that step forward
yeah and it's super interesting too that
you actually went through the exercise
of exploring other ideas other markets
and I think a lot of people there
sitting at home and they caught with an
idea or the front element idea and they
like oh somebody should go build that
business right and it's kind of about
the surface level sounds like a great
idea as you know from going through it
and many people who've looked at
companies what looks like a good idea on
the surface actually may not be scalable
and as good as you thought it was what
was the work that you did was it just
intuition that said hey that sounds like
a good idea but ends up not being
successful or were you like running
numbers and spreadsheets and really
trying to understand the economics of
certain businesses and then deciding not
to go forward with them yeah I mean it
was it's interesting because what I
ended up doing with with Everly well and
the idea that I that I ended up quitting
my job over and launching I did not know
I mean I did some but nowhere near as
much detailed work as I had done for all
these other industries which I'm not
sure what that says if that's really
some
anyone else should go do but it's the
reality but to your point before that I
had done a lot of business laning I had
looked at industries I would take you
know the parent or child and parent and
his baby industry I would take the
travel industry to take the payments
industry I would sit down and whiteboard
and brainstorm with a friend interested
in the space for days weeks even hours
take an afternoon and look at where the
opportunity was what was oversaturated
look at total addressable market look at
the competitors understand the problem
and to your point I have ideas every
single day where I'm like oh my gosh I
wish someone would go build this company
but again that is not there's so many
different factors you have to look at
including timing and ability to kind of
get in at the right time in the market
and all of these frankly and this gets
back a little bit to how much is passion
play a role because passion drives
resilience for founder's which is which
is perhaps the number one important
quality I would look at travel and I'd
be like gosh I'm so bored by this right
that's for me personally that's not
because it's not a good space it just
didn't speak to me in a way where all I
could find reasons to not do all of
these ideas and then that would
overpower wanting to kind of make the
leap and so it is it should be grounded
in reality
market size competitive all those
Caprona target fit all those kind of
things
which is what I did but then at some
point you also just have to make the
leap and something's gonna have to tip
the scales how much of having gone to
business school gave you the rules to be
able to in the confidence to go do this
versus do you think you would have been
able to actually quit a job and go start
without having that education um so look
for for context for everyone listening
or watching I went to Harvard Business
School which I think was a unique both
moment in time of when I was at Harvard
and the cohort that I was surrounded by
as well as a unique opportunity to steep
myself in entrepreneurship and so it was
part classroom
but it was vast majority my exposure to
incredible founders and entrepreneurs
we're friends and so for kind of the
context of the economic time is my class
entered September 2009 many of my
classmates had just been laid off from
their investment banking job Lehman
Brothers or wherever in the fall of Oh
eight and the graduating class you know
obviously had it was in the thick of it
from unemployment at cetera and so we
entered at was the height of the
recession exited in a decent job market
but that was the beginning Oh a no.9 was
the beginning of Harvard Business School
shift towards entrepreneurial ISM versus
private equity venture capital in
consulting not that that still doesn't
play a role but it's really I think
become a school known for for founders
and so I was surrounded personally by
the launches of Gilt Groupe
Rent the Runway Birchbox I could go on
and then in my class alone we had stitch
fix Katrina Lake there's one of a shear
of peak I had to unicorn founders in my
section alone so when you think about
this it's not so much that I went in at
all thinking that this is my pad I went
in knowing consulting was not my path
and trying to use that time to discover
what it was and I was able to be
immersed in this really unique
environment for both entrepreneurs and
female founders to be honest and I said
look my classmates are brilliant and
smart but if they can do it so can i and
so that was really a turning point for
me it was a confidence booster I didn't
go in particularly confident or
self-assured into HBS and so I certainly
think the turning point for me was my
business school education but not so
much necessarily because of the
education itself but the environment
that it created as a ground for me to
get my footing my favorite part of your
story is mainly because I could see
pretty much every parent doing this is
after you go to HBS and you get a great
job and kind of
crushing it if you will in terms of your
career you can call your parents say
alright this is fun but I might go do
this other thing and whoa I don't see I
know and I think you know I'm really
fortunate I've always had two incredibly
supportive parents but I think it comes
from a place of just worry right and
making sure that you know - my parents
credit for whatever reason I always had
this innate work ethic ambition and kind
of determination that they had to
actually pull back so I was always the
kid like I was a perfectionist I would
run myself into the ground and still do
right and and that's my personal
challenge to manage but I think for
their standpoint it was look you've just
been a running hard for like ten years
straight
you've been running so hard at this job
like have you had the time to think this
through right and then knowing at the
time you know something I haven't
touched on a lot but I told in the past
is my my husband and I got married in
May of 2014 he decided to quit his job
in bootstrap a company a different non
adventure type company a services
company and so when I quit my job in the
summer of 2015 that was a decision we
had made together right because I had a
good corporate salary we're like we're
just married it'll be fine but we went
down to a significant income reduction
and sold our house that we had owned
only for 12 months and moved into a
two-bedroom apartment and so it is not
it sounds very dramatic and it was
dramatic
these are moves that we both supported
and we made but the reality is of being
a founder is you have to also clean out
those choices as well and just think
about the reality of your own financial
implications and making sure that you're
prepared for that because it can sound
glamorous or may be like a fairy tale
that you're gonna get to the end of and
be able to tell the bad parts but it
could also just be really bad
and so I think being able to know what
you're getting into and make some smart
choices that was another piece of the
path that I'm sure everyone else thought
was crazy
knowing that you wanted to start a
company and still working a corporate
job but having your husband quit his job
and start a business what was that like
I gotta imagine there's an element of
like and that kind of looks fun over
there yeah I mean his path was tough he
ultimately did have a great exit from
that business in 2016 but it his path
was not for the faint of heart he was
also on the road five days a week for
that and so you know I think our thought
process at the moment we were it feels
like it was you know decades ago but six
years ago different life time was okay
great so we've we've not combined
incomes we have no idea what that even
looks like so this is the perfect time
when we only were engaged for five
months we had known each other for two
years and we got married we had never
lived together and we had you know
basically had had no idea what it was
gonna be like to be married but what a
great time for him to quit his job give
up this salary and for us to make all
these life changes it's gonna be gonna
be fantastic right and then you know a
year later this might be some premarital
advice for you but uh but I'm in a year
later to say actually now we were yeah
but one income let's go down to
drastically reduced from both of our
incomes right so I think it we learned a
lot and I think it was for me you know I
never viewed it for me it was an
opportunity for him that I was really
excited about him having and I knew it
was the right thing for him to do but
certainly you know I appreciated his
support back when I then came to him
which was not in the plan and said hey I
also want to leave my job so that was
you know that was I think an interesting
time and then also of course when we
decided to move to Austin another year
after that so you're you're smiling so I
know that there's a lot
what ultimately kind of why the
healthcare space in why lab testing for
you so did you know when you quit that's
exactly what you were gonna go do or was
it I want to go sort of business and you
know I'm serious I'm gonna go find this
idea but I got a cap
well I did quit one job with the
situation that you just described and
then got picked up for my job at
MoneyGram which ended up being an
incredible career experience I'm so glad
I did but I quit my job out of business
school to give I'd saved money to
basically give myself nine months to go
figure it out and then you know kind of
couldn't get rid of the bug and so then
when at MoneyGram actually went through
this health experience which I'll talk
about in a second that then gave me the
idea and so I knew I was gonna go do it
I didn't officially start working on
everly well until about two months after
I left but I thought was for sure what I
was gonna go do and I knew that I had
funding lined up to do it and you know
for me again
I hadn't even explored I didn't do a
huge canvas of the healthcare space
I personally it was on great health
insurance I was in my 20s and I started
having what you hear almost every woman
talked about at some point which is
brain fog chronic fatigue aches and
pains totally erratic and unexplainable
symptoms and I began this healthcare
Odyssey that ultimately resulted in
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars of lab testing fees that were
covered and I never got results for and
was left wholly unsatisfied with my
experience and so that's really what
prompted me digging into the into the
issue area and then making the decision
to leave so would it be safe to say that
you are an expert at WebMD and I know up
the entire website searching around yes
yeah although you know it's interesting
I'm not a hypochondriac and I'm not a
I'm not an overly I really had
we bad symptoms right like nothing I've
ever had in my life and so I think
having that experience where you're like
gosh I wake up and for days on days and
then months you're not yourself I think
that is really disconcerting for people
and ultimately when it ended up being
something so simple for me it was like
six months of all these doctors and
specialists and all running their own
tests and that it ultimately end up
being like three hormone imbalances and
then several vitamin deficiencies severe
anemia things like that but ultimately
nothing nothing that life-changing you
almost have this reaction like well
couldn't that have been sussed out a
different way and rebalanced and so it's
just this reaction in the healthcare
system largely because of how the whole
complex is set up that that's how you
know you have to kind of maneuver to try
to get to the end goal but yeah it was
it was a frustrating experience and I
think one that like I what did end up
googling all my lab results right and
trying to figure out what they all meant
when I couldn't really get any answers
or even any like anything beyond oh it
was fine you're fine your levels are
fine so you know then then I think
that's when people started to take
things into their own hands yeah it's
interesting too because you know as you
think about health care and the more
that you talk to I think people who have
spent time in the space like they
realize the body is a machine right and
yeah it's got emotions and kind of all
the things that make us intelligent life
and also but then today it is a machine
and agnostic testing and lab testing is
trying to just like you diagnose what's
wrong with your car right it should
diagnose what's wrong with the body
but the processes I'll use the word
broken you may not use that word but
maybe just talk a little bit about like
what are the issues in the legacy model
and then we can get into kind of what
the idea for Everly was and until you've
built yeah I mean I think why health
care continues to be both broken and yet
have so many people try to fix it to
varying degrees successfully or not
successfully
because there are hundreds of different
interrelated and interwoven factors
where you pull one lever and you make it
better you affect the next and so if you
look at this spaghetti web whether its
primary care whether its specialty care
whether its hospitals surgeries lab
testing prescriptions these are all
factors that play into an overall what I
call industrial complex that is broken
in so many ways and often because the
incentives are so misaligned not because
any one party is saying I want to not
provide good health care right that is
not the goal I don't believe I really
believe that people's goal is to treat
patients and the most effective way
possible but we don't get there because
it's so broken and so for my experience
specifically and I think what I see a
lot of especially and women's health but
even more broadly as you go to a
physician that physician is either a
specialist or a generalist they are
under immense amounts of pressure
billing time and appointments
documentation all of these things
they're doing the best they can with
limited information and time and then
they have to order tests and then they
have to make decisions about what
they're gonna order based on how you
relate to their particular specialty and
otherwise you're refer you elsewhere and
what I really think a lot of the problem
is today is a lot of your services are
disconnected from your core physician so
whether that's an MRI or a lab or a
surgery you have all these different
services that your insurance is going to
get billed for you as the patient don't
know how they relate you don't know what
they're going to cost even with
insurance and then you ultimately don't
have someone coordinating centrally on
what all this means for you unless you
are part of concierge medicine right
which is again typically reserved for
kind of the wealthy and for people who
can afford that and so I think it is
just a model that needs so much change
and yet there's not one way to change it
it's going to fix it and so you have
all of these different pieces that make
it very difficult to affect change
unless you are in this moment when I
think there's been a lot of good change
on the regulatory front with the
pandemic so we can talk about that later
but yeah I think that's that's the
holistic view that I have I focus a lot
on access and price transparency because
those are two of the particular areas
where I think I can help and where I
think a lot of Americans put put a
particular focus but those are not the
only two issues right it's so much
broader than that that's just where I
think that I can play a role for sure
and so after you go through this
experience you're like alright this is
an interesting area I think that this
can be improved what was the original
idea for every little everly well I mean
why the move to Austin specifically
don't like good start and didn't do this
so in a you know be interesting to do to
run some actual like research data on
companies may be you know put Series B
Series C or even beyond and what their
original offering was versus their how
their product and their acts how their
offering has evolved we are pretty true
to the core mission and like the very
first business plan it did originally
focus for like a week on maybe two weeks
on maternal testing and more around
mother and child
breast milk nutrition testing hormone
testing things like that and ultimately
my read on market size was that was
going to be too limiting for an entire
business that I wanted to be paradigm
shifting so however that's a product
perspective the mission of the company
was always to provide access to
affordable and convenient tests that you
could do in the home and that you could
have digital results that are yours but
then also shared with your doctor if
needed and I think that that you know
doesn't it doesn't sound particularly
sexy as a model but what I what I saw in
parallel that we've seen become true
is what Warby Parker did for eyeglasses
which are commodity what pillpack and
others has done for pharmacy which is a
commodity
instacart for groceries again a
commodity mattresses the list goes on
and on this model has been done in very
old-school industries that typically had
large entrenched players with heavy
brick-and-mortar infrastructures and
being able to use technology a
transportation another great example so
being able to use technology to make a
commoditized experience useful for a
consumer I think is something that we
were able to take those models and then
bring them in a little bit I really well
but it the product back then is very
similar in terms of vision as it is
today
what I didn't predict is how important
this service even before the current
moment how important this service is to
all age groups and all demographics and
that moment for us really happened on
our Shark Tank airing in 2017 we saw a
radical shift in the demographics of our
consumer base shift from female to male
shift towards things like cholesterol
heart health STI testing and that I
think really set a path for us to think
about our platform as a service for
essential health needs versus our
platform as a service for people frankly
like me who were unable to get the
answers that they needed and really
pursued health there's a big difference
there in terms of being a core
healthcare delivery service versus
someone something tangential that's
supplemental and we went from being
supplemental to essential hasta it I
didn't cover Austin yet but I could go
ahead okay so I started the company in
Dallas and you know I started in Dallas
not because I had a particular view on
the location of Dallas but because
that's where we lived that's where our
home why our families where he owned a
house at the time and so I I had the
company there from kind of you know
honest September 2015 when we started by
we it was me working for my apartment
and then until March of 2016
a super long time line but I will tell
you that I decided to go out and raise
an equity round of financing pre-launch
and I parallel path angel investors and
VC's because I wanted to just have those
conversations and start the process of
speaking with VCS and unanimously at the
time which this just shifted a bit and I
think will continue to shift um
west coast and east coast VC's had
largely not done deals in Dallas in the
tech space in that fast-growing consumer
tech space and so their concerns were we
don't know our network in Dallas we
don't know that as a foundation for
recruiting the best and brightest talent
it wasn't a criticism of Dallas it was a
reflection of a pattern and what they
had seen work and having concerns about
that not to mention I was a first time
founder a female founder a non-technical
founder and a solo founder with no
experience in healthcare so like like
not a problem at all like were you so
mad that he was like no I would have
rejected me I would I get it I totally
get it
it takes a lot of a great vote of risk
and faith from usually angel investors
early on right so you know I think that
framing really caused me though to take
a look at the talent market in Dallas
and so I started trying to recruit and I
found that because there was no
substantial start-up talent market all
of the people I was talking to had
really ridiculous and outsized comp
requests for like employee number one
like 200k a year and twenty five percent
of the company you know and I'm like
listen like it's just not a reality and
so I knew from AngelList and for my
friends that that where the Rangers
should be and I also looked at what was
happening in Austin and there had been a
number of successful exits there there
was an entire tech community and so my
husband and I agreed that if I could
raise the seed round of funding which
closed February 16 2016 then we would
move to Austin which we did March 8 we
rented a townhouse without seeing it and
ultimately moved down on the first day
of South by Southwest because we were
obviously neophytes in the Austin scene
not the data moves Austin and at that
and as we were on unloading boxes I did
in-person interviews in Austin for
people I'd already started recruiting
over the phone and had about four
employees within the next six weeks so
what is it like starting a new business
moving and all at the same time doing it
well South by Southwest is going on I
can over yeah that chaos created by that
you know it's funny I think about so
many moments of just sheer chaos in this
journey right sheer chaos sheer unknowns
situations that you don't know how
you're going to solve and in the moment
and maybe this is part of having to be
level-headed as a founder it doesn't
feel that chaotic reflecting back it
certainly was but it just felt like what
you needed to do to move the business
forward and it was changed but I think
if you choose to be in this life and in
this lifestyle of entrepreneurship I
think that's a little bit of the norm
and so it was a you know it was unique
for sure but it was something where it
just felt really right and it felt like
this was the best chance for the
business to succeed and I wanted to hire
the best people that I could and I also
knew I could recruit from California and
from New York to Austin which is very
much been the case and I didn't know
that I could do that in Dallas so it
really it just made sense and it was
just it was kind of a no-brainer
no-brainer decision to like bring this
to like if I was really gonna do this I
had to I had to be all that yeah so
let's talk a little bit about what
exactly you're doing today and kind of
how the business operates what areas are
bigger than others and kind of any
updates that you want to share
yeah so I'll just give a little brief
overview on on how it really well
actually works essentially we have
provided access to Americans to 35
different products of different lab
tests and they span from STI testing to
food sensitivity testing allergy testing
indoor/outdoor allergies hormones etc
what is unique about our product is we
have a brand and an entire
infrastructure where you as an
individual can go on our website order a
test we have an independent physician
network that is involved in reviewing
the tests and then the results and then
you collect your sample at home and that
can be a blood drop several blood drops
urine saliva etc you send it in and you
get results that are easily explained
color coded able to be sent to your
doctor able to be shared within about
three to five days and you know I think
in theory this doesn't sound that
groundbreaking but I think when you look
at lab testing and if you think about
your own lab testing experience the last
one maybe that you did for a physical
you generally have to take time off work
you put down your credit card you don't
know how much it's gonna cost
hopefully it's covered you maybe get the
results or someone calls you you don't
really know and if you're lucky maybe
get access online and you don't really
know how it plays at your health
decisions and for millions of people
that experience just doesn't work but
you know when we launched we had three
tests our first seven months in business
in 2016 we launched in beta like the
summer in 2016 we did seven hundred
thousand in sales and in 2019 we did
North forty million so and I could tell
you this was before out home health
testing became on the tip of everyone's
tongue and an important theme in how
health care delivery would change moving
forward
in a post or I guess Cova nineteen world
if it's post or continuing koba nineteen
world and so part of that growth was
really product market fit around
accessibility bad experience with lab
testing needing to get answers with
their doc with people's doctors so we
had a really good business before we
also before this moment we also are
naturally distributed and target Kroger
and CVS and we have a Medicare business
where we do at home health testing for
colon cancer diabetes and kidney disease
on our marquee partner there is Humana
so we've really diversified the business
in a big way and I think found that it's
so much more than just I think a lot of
people think it's curiosity for people
much like maybe a 23andme test it's so
much more than that this is something
people rely on who don't have insurance
who don't know if they can go and get
the tests that they need it's really
essential for many of those people and I
think that's then the biggest shift over
the years but we've really grown
tremendously quickly and now we're in
this situation again of looking at hyper
scale and trying to figure out how we
respond as a business which is the
moment we're currently living in yeah so
I can't remember exactly when we
invested either 10 to 16 of 2017 I
remember at the end of 2018 you
basically sent a an update out and that
update was kind of you know here's how
we did this year and here's our general
goals for 2019 and I'll never forget the
moment I opened the email and I saw the
revenue projection for 2019 and I would
have picked the phone and I called Jason
my partner and I said Jason am I reading
this right they really think they're
gonna do 40 million dollars or more in
revenue and and he said well that would
be great
it's like wow this reaction was just
like sure and and then you guys ended up
going and doing it and so just like
going from you know in what three years
give or take not even ever having
started a business I'm really knowing
kind of is this going to work or not to
doing over 40 million dollars in annual
revenue
how does that happen like how much of
that is just trial by fire how much of
that is like let's go find the smartest
people we can and bring them like how do
you actually do that yeah it's
interesting because I couldn't like if
you had asked me in 2015 like
envisioning success
I couldn't even visualize a million
dollars in sales I could not even
visualize it and then you know I'm
sitting here now realizing how much my
perspective has changed when I'm looking
at numbers looking at you know thirty
million dollar deals that were able to
get and looking at ten million dollar
months and it is a moment of reflection
for sure and it's something that I do
not take for granted and it certainly
has not been because of me I have been
the consistent thread for better or
worse throughout every every moment and
I am still here and I am resilient but
certainly you know so many factors play
into this and I often am asked like how
do you do it how do you scale and then
also like what are the number what are
the top things that made this happen and
it's I think there's really maybe three
things one is you have to be in the
business 24/7 that doesn't mean working
24/7 but you have this is your life as a
founder for it is you live it you
breathe it it's on your mind and so you
have to be damn sure that you love it
because it is not worth it
no one should start a company to want to
make money that is the worst absolute
reason to start a company you should
start a company because you want to
change the world and it is very very
hard and you will find yourself living
and breeding this for so long that you
have to be resilient and committed and
just not quit so I think for me
personally maybe that's the role that
I've played as a leader but I think more
broadly you know I didn't have the
benefit
of having the reputation or the
investors to go hire really great
expensive people early on and it's those
people generally wouldn't have come to
work for me it's not to say we had
exceptional early stage employees but I
couldn't bring in like a really seasoned
executive that had had all this track
record because they weren't going to
take the risk on you know this brand and
so every step of the way I have just
continuously up leveled the team added
to the team thought about where my skill
gaps were thought about what the
business needed and I think that has
been a big part of it I went from being
a pretty bad hire of talent not meaning
I hired bad people I just didn't quite
know what the role needed what the right
skill set was what level you know kind
of all that matching that you have to do
in those early days we have limited
budgets
to being really crisp on who we need and
when and the team and I think that's
made all the difference I mean at this
point with 80 people and with a really
seasoned executive team it's much more
about them than about me but what I do
bring I think is just an unwavering
commitment to the business no matter
what and I think that that drives a lot
of respect from the team and that is
something that as a founder you have to
be ready to do but it is I've done every
role in the business I was the growth
hacker other than coding to be clear
that I that I have not done I have to
have people that I trust to do that
customer care I used to be the person on
the chat I finally like changed my name
and I think remove my pictures I was
like maybe people will think it's weird
that the CEO is customer service and you
know then have hired really good
clinical and tech talent but it's not
there's no secret formula you know we
didn't get traction for like six weeks
and I thought the business was dead
because that was my standard it takes
like a year to get traction right and I
just kept hacking it with the team and
we ended up you know getting really good
traction in the first six months and
again it has to be a moment in the
market you really have to understand the
problem and you just have to be
committed to whatever problem you face
working around it and that's really what
it takes but it's it's also
something that if you think it's the
idea or if you think it's you both of
those are wrong you know and I think
it's interesting for your business
because 2016 2 let's say 2019 is kind of
the pre-core ona virus age if you will
now in 19 until you know hopefully
forever is a very different environment
and so business model itself hasn't
changed but the environment in which
you're operating is changed drastically
right how have you navigated that and
then as you think of just healthcare
more broadly whether it's telemedicine
lab testing except for like how does
that change moving forward yeah so I
think let's let's talk first about
Everly Wells environment in general
outside of even us providing or working
to provide Koba 19 testing because we
have suddenly I've been I've been
fighting this battle for five years
talking about how people are how lab
testing is broken and Americans are
getting screwed right lab testing is
cheap it can be affordable you should
know how much your tests are going to
cost period like there is no excuse for
that
especially as you're having to pay for
it out of pocket more and more there's a
great New York Times headline last
summer that said they want it to be a
secret how the same blood test cost
between eleven to a thousand dollars
depending on what zip code you live it
I mean that's crazy so and there's all
kinds of explanations for it right but
regardless the bottom line is you as the
individual end up paying not difference
depending on your zip code and so I had
seen this as a problem for so long
understanding that we had a really hard
battle of both educating the American
public on why this matters how to do it
and creating a brand around it like this
is both a category creation as well as a
branch creation and so that takes a lot
of effort and it's not something to take
it takes years right took 23andme a
decade and so I think in the same vein
we have been been at this for a while
and it had great growth and then this
moment has happened that sheds light for
Americans on something frankly I and my
team were well aware of which is the
medical testing supply chain all of the
broken pieces of it the under investment
in our infrastructure and then that it
takes a long time to ramp and scale
capacity in lab testing and you can't
just snap your fingers and suddenly have
a solution especially for a novel virus
and so all of a sudden people care about
this in a way that they didn't I believe
that testing will become quite a topic
any talk track for the 2020 election I
believe people now have a deep interest
in understanding why they can't get a
test that should be available and we can
broaden that a lot more in their minds
around why testing in general is
important and we're already seeing that
so as an example over the last two and a
half months our core testing categories
have grown anywhere from two hundred to
five hundred percent those are
categories like STI testing cholesterol
hba1c endocrine and then our overall
business has has grown anywhere from you
know depending on the week one hundred
to three hundred percent and so that is
a very unique position to be in as well
and it just reflects consumer behavior
and it reflects people not wanting to go
to doctors offices and then even on the
Medicare side we know we know that colon
cancer screenings are down 70% year over
a year 82 million Americans need to be
screened every year for colon cancer and
people just aren't going and there's a
home test for that right and that's a
lot of the demand that we're seeing both
for enterprise partners as well as from
just individuals in wanting to do this
and so we have a really unique challenge
to face because I think that this change
is permanent I think the telemedicine
legislation changes will be permanent I
think that Everly well now can be part
of your core
health care delivery and instead of
maybe tangential or as the next step
when you've exhausted other options and
what that means is then we have to think
about our business model a little bit
differently how do we think about being
products that everyone can afford that
is reimbursable that has a fully
integrated supply chain that we can
really scale and I think that you will
see behavior around health care delivery
change permanently from here and we this
is our moment to really respond and show
the value of what we have and if we
can't do it now then we shouldn't we
should be here you know and make it's
part of this so you talked about the
transparency but also consumer behavior
right and so there's obviously a ton of
people who are speculating on the idea
of I don't want to go outside there's a
virus in some places my government won't
let me even go outside so I need to stay
inside I still need to get health care
services no-brainer let me order
something off and run it right and now I
can ignition to test myself part of the
experience of going to a doctor though
is like whether it's true or not the
person in the white coat is the doctor
right and being there there's a sense of
safety or security they're supposed to
know what's going on I think generally
they do yeah when you do the test at
home there's more of a removal maybe
from that you guys address from the
consumer behavior can change but then
okay what are the tests meet right kind
of what you were talking about earlier
like I get the results but like how do I
interpret that or how do I change my
behavior in order to affect my health
right right and I think this this does
depend on which types of tests we're
talking about right a vitamin D test we
have different actions to take them an
STI test obviously but even today we
already have about 10 diagnostic tests
like rst I suite where we have four
years leverage telehealth to be able to
be the intervening physician
independently both in the wording of the
test and in the consult afterward and
even prescribing we're applicable that's
included in the cost so this is not an
additional costs that you pay and pay
one upfront price and I think that that
model is what you're seeing evolve into
and it's one where I think we haven't
done a good job is that really well of
making it clear that our model is
actually comprehensive and end-to-end
now we cannot replace nor can
telemedicine replace the value of that
physical in-person visit we also don't
aim to replace the value of the doctor
and in fact we've built the platform to
be physician agnostic such that we make
sure that you share your results with
your physician and we know actually this
has been the most interesting part maybe
a surprising insight that we've had
because so let's walk through this case
study so you put your doctor writes a
lot requisition you walk down the hall
you put your credit cards on you get the
lab done you then get a bill for $500
for a thyroid test and the bill on the
back says you're your doctor may or may
not have told you that we build for this
separately do do you call
you call your doctor and you get mapped
and so we know from surveying our our
consumers are talking to them about a
quarter of our customers their doctor
referred them to us and said send me the
results because the physician doesn't
want to field those calls it's not their
fault it's not their fault what they're
saying is hey I can run this through
your insurance in the lab well I don't
know how much it's gonna cost I know
that I really well has this test it's
you know forty nine dollars it's yours
covered by your HSA it's your call just
make sure I get the results then we can
talk about them and so I think this
acceptance of the model has already
started to shift and then with this
pandemic and with the shift broadly to
telemedicine now doctors want to be able
to order their patients at home kit
directly and so I think that you'll both
have this consumer initiated channel of
like hey self-directed I am symptoms I
want to get an STI test and I want to
work with one of the telemedicine
physicians but you'll also have just the
opposite which is physicians referring
people into the platform and that's
something we've already seen in a bit of
an offline way yeah it's super
interesting I guess because really what
you end up doing is you're disrupting a
model but you're actually disrupting it
not just from logistical II how do I
give you the tests and you take it at
home which are actually disrupting the
model by the referral component right
and you're actually solving a problem
for the doctors it sounds like which
completely changes that consumer
behavior because again I trust the white
coat right and you should yeah and then
talk a little bit about the price
transparency when people hear you say
things like a blood test can cost eleven
dollars or a thousand dollars one they
get mad right - they're confused and
then three they probably go check their
bills and see did they get the eleven
dollar one or the thousand dollar one
you know why I guess has this not
changed is it literally because they're
profiting off of the lack of education
or there are other components that that
play into it it's other components it
has everything to do with
well it has everything first to do with
what is your insurance plan and even if
a physician or a lab is trying to check
that where you are in your deductible
your planned coverage all those things
there are also you know tens of millions
of Americans uninsured which we forget
about it's not an it's not an
insignificant population and then of
course underinsured as well and don't
have the coverage they need but even if
you have good insurance it often falls
in the category of were you diagnosed
with something is there the right coding
and how the requisition was coded or
they're the right codes are you in the
right demographic for this to be covered
so I'll give you my own personal example
many years ago maybe in 2014 this was
before all my chronic fatigue I was
still feeling fatigued and my OB Jen
said I always recommend a vitamin D test
as one of the first steps she said but I
have to tell you because you're not over
40 it will likely not be covered and
it'll be probably four to five hundred
dollars and so she said instead you
could just like let's work on a
supplementation plan and see if you feel
better but if you were over 40 it would
be covered so that it's a lot of
arbitrary and and may be clinically
supported at a time but arbitrary rules
that end up being able to not accurately
predict how much the test is going to
cost you as the person right and a lot
of this shift has happened and why I
think the attention hasn't been on it is
the for kind of 2010 ish era the last
ten years people didn't pay much for
their health care high deductible plans
or a new invention healthcare savings
@ff flexible healthcare savings accounts
and flexible spending accounts are a new
invention of the last decade ish and new
meaning in mass so like something like
sixty or seventy percent of American
families are on high deductible
healthcare plans that means there's a
lot more cost that then end up either
not being covered if they're out of
network or out of pocket or you're still
having to pay for and so there's more
on the fact that oh my gosh I got this
blood test on that I got no value from
it I'm now getting a separate bill for
$400 like why would I pay this and how
did I get into this situation and so I
think it's a number of factors again of
the entire infrastructure being broken
and and look I mean 13 billion tests are
run annually almost everyone has to have
a blood test annually and so this is not
like a niche problem in healthcare it
may not be a particularly you know
glamorous vertical but it is a huge it's
like going to the DMV everyone has to do
it everyone hates it and it's not a
great experience yeah it's absolutely
wild to kind of see when you really you
know pull back the curtain if you will
and kind of see how a lot of this goes
how much of your success and kind of the
consumer behavior change do you think is
healthcare related meaning the doctor is
telling them go change the behavior or
now with kovat people are saying home
versus something like other aspects of
their life they're ordering off of
Amazon or other types of you know kind
of e-commerce or direct-to-consumer type
services and of course now once they get
that experience in the non healthcare
sector they want to bring that over and
that's their expectation in healthcare
yeah I think it's a combination I mean I
think without and and I point to 23andme
a lot I mean 10 years ago or you know 15
years ago would you ever have put a
sample in the u.s. mail would anyone
nobody would have put a biological
sample in the mail right and this was
being you know home health hasn't been
done for decades for certain conditions
but and mass you would not have a
critical mass of Americans doing this
for 23andme and ancestry and so I think
that behavior was crucial to developing
the consumer memory the muscle memory
and then I think so much of the shift of
the world for consumer and direct to
consumer shifted to online that I think
people had experience in it so it wasn't
just that though because there were
other companies that tried this model
the years and the timing was not right
consumers did not have enough pain from
this process to want to convert to an
utterly well experience and I say this
because it's not like our customers are
not people that are like oh and curious
let me buy this it is people who time
after time the health care system has
failed them and they want a better
solution and they're working with their
doctor and they need access to testing
that is affordable and they don't want
to be surprised that is who our customer
base says and so that situation didn't
exist to the degree it does today
unfortunately for today but
unfortunately you know over a decade ago
and so you had companies launch like for
quantified Sulphurs expensive price
points concierge medicine testing
different iterations not too different
from what I really well does but we are
the first company to focus on accessible
price points for everyone for core
testing not for testing on the fringes
not for you know quantified Sulphurs but
really for everyone and I think that is
a different model and one that wouldn't
have worked ten years ago and that's why
other companies didn't work back then
either
this really timing is so important and I
can't say that's credit to me I didn't
actually fully understand how quickly
all this would shift around cost but it
has unfortunately we have served as more
and more of a parachute for people how
much pressure is this putting on the
legacy world like I'm assuming that the
big monolithic healthcare system is not
going to just stand by why you print
tens of millions of dollars in revenue
and say you know we don't care about
that what have you seen either in
response from legacy players or do you
see maybe not direct responses but like
behavior changes or anything that yeah I
mean you know the two largest players in
lab testing or two publicly traded
companies quest diagnostics and LabCorp
they are you know they're huge companies
and they focus on a very different part
of the service delivery model Rd
brick-and-mortar owning the lab value
chain we do not own the
value-chain we partner across the
country right so they really are in a
different business my argument would be
they're not in the business that serves
the patient that does not mean that they
don't care about the patient they're
just in all these different types of
businesses for where their competency is
we have great relationships with both of
them to be honest I'm not sure we're yet
big enough to cause them any pain I have
seen though they've both revamped or
relaunched their direct-to-consumer or
consumer initiated businesses in the
last 18 months to two years and most
recently
LabCorp launched pixel kind of took
shuddered it a bit and then is
relaunched it as part of their code at
19 response and then Quest has a quest
direct business to go in and have blood
draws that they've they've amped up a
lot of their social advertising social
media advertising on I think what is
undervalued by most healthcare
organizations this is not not specific
to LabCorp inquest is the value of
community customer experience and brand
and that is something that is difficult
to build we have an NPS score across the
business of a 70 plus 70 that is
world-class for a lab test this is how
passionately people feel about our
service
LabCorp and quest NPS is negative so I
share this because but to be clear it's
not because they're not providing value
it's the question of who is the value
for who is the value for and so as the
value will shift more towards the
patient and the consumer I do think
you'll start to see pressure across
across the Sahel --the care delivery
chain right is this is the moment for
the consumerization of health care we've
heard that phrase forever we've heard
the phrase personalized health we've
heard the phrase digital health all of
this is different ways of caring about
the patient and I think you'll finally
start to see that come to the head and
companies and large organizations have
to do something about it do you see a
world where that
brick-and-mortar kind of much more I'll
call bureaucrats probably the wrong word
but but just much more brick-and-mortar
in a kind of physical world approach to
lab testing there will definitely be lab
tests that always have to be that way
of course yeah trend more towards this
at-home direct-to-consumer kind of what
you're doing or do you think there will
be coexistence of the two models right
for tests that can be at home and done
destruction consumer way I think until
we have innovation around blood
collection I think that the two models
will coexist there are many companies
working on this I really well exists to
hopefully partner with the companies
that are successful in doing that or
until we have a say innovation where
tests that are conducted usually via
blood can now be done via saliva or
urine or some other method so I think
that is really the next frontier is how
can we innovate around blood collection
such that it can it can really happen
and much more mass adoption and shift
away from these slick and mortar needs
which are expensive infrastructure and
yes they will have to exist for tests
that naturally have to be done that way
but there's a quite a large number of
common tests that don't have to be done
in a brick-and-mortar setting and so I
think that innovation will be the next
step our goal is to be agnostic and say
hey when there is a great innovation
that is fda-approved we want to be
providing that experience to our
consumers and it puts us in a really
good position to capitalize on that once
it's available for people yeah and what
I want to wrap up talking about is I was
very unaware of the I don't know I'll
call it maybe not unintelligent but uh
inefficient regulations that were in
place around a lot of the telemedicine
stuff so simple things like you can't
use the iPhone right for FaceTime and or
you can't do across state lines type
telemedicine and and some of this it
sounds like has been changed over the
last couple of years some of that's been
more like I'm
emergency measures yeah changed baby
just give us an understanding of like
how do you see this playing out and do
we get to a world where you know there's
the big talk in the food delivery space
is cloud kitchens like do we get to like
a cloud doctor situation where
everything is delivered through a
telemedicine that can be I don't want to
I think it's too radical to say that we
don't need physical and person visits
there is so much about what doctors do
that requires that oversight even from a
primary care standpoint let's talk about
primary care versus emerging emergent or
specialty needs but I think that a lot
of it for the doctors sake as well the
practice of medicine all those problems
I talked about earlier in this
conversation documentation love it's a
time all of those things you can get a
lot of freedom I think by doing at least
interim appointments and management via
telemedicine I think it is here to stay
in a very big way across practices
across specialties especially in mental
health and especially for people
managing chronic conditions do you I
mean so many conditions require you to
go see a doctor every 90 days to your
prescription rate at all that feels
quite dated for many of these conditions
and so you saw a 10x increase already in
telemedicine you saw the Medicare
restrictions around telemedicine
evaporate overnight I don't think that
that shifts back to in the physician's
office but I think it's because you're
gonna see physicians in favor of it as
much as patients and there's gonna be
some you know kinks to work out but I
think by and large this is also the the
moment that telemedicine needed to
really take hold and hearing that the
physician may actually want this makes
their job easier sure it would be fair
to say that actually there can be a
significant economic impact in a
positive way for the physicians to start
to incorporate more of this technology
and kind of do things that actually
scale them and
our staff so they can see more patients
and drive more revenue yeah you know
physician practice revenue is a complex
topic that I'm frankly not as educated
on and I know has been under fire or has
been declining for physicians for a
number of years and but I know from
having looked and partnering with a lot
of telemedicine companies that's the
pitch right the pitches that it makes
your practice more efficient more
effective you're using technology all
those things it'll be interesting to see
your doctor on demand and you have
intelidox those are kind of different
than what I think you see them practice
by practice telemedicine companies that
are getting rolled out in this pandemic
right there's these companies that serve
individual practices and then there's
the more national networks and so what I
don't know is how will these practice by
practice companies fare and those
practices versus being able to go to a a
natural network like tell a topic my
insurance covers tella doc and using
that instead of maybe my my PCP that I
would have used and so that might be an
interesting Robin disruption that we see
where we're hoping that it provides a
better economic case for these small
practices and it may or may not in the
long term yeah it's super interesting to
finish up I asked everyone the same two
questions then you get to ask me one
what is the most important book you've
ever read that I've ever read
I think the most important book I've
ever read gosh I mean ever is a really
tough term but let me say the most
impactful book of like my last decade
was hard thing about hard things because
I read it and I reread it often but I
read it in a moment where I think
oftentimes as a founder you feel very
alone and isolated you're the only one
you think you're the only one going
through these problems that have such a
clear articulation of their real
challenges just people I mean companies
are people and the challenges of just
how do you make sure that you're doing
this the best you can and yet pushing
through and really tough moments I was
really powerful for me and I think it
was a very honest view of what it takes
and in the particular moment when I
first read it but it made such an impact
on me I think that was why so that's
that's probably the the most impactful
book for me of the last decade my
favorite part of that book is how raw he
is with us right like there's no sugar
coating whatsoever and even though he
explains things that he was thinking
about doing but ended up not doing which
I think it's super helpful right and
just saying like this is how bad it was
and here's how we got out of it and not
that I wanted you know a story about how
about it was for foreign words but I
think it was such an honest and raw look
in a way in a world where it's all about
funding rounds and new products and
media and all those things in that
that's really changed I think obviously
for startups in the last several years
is about attention and typically when
you talk to a founder by the way their
reaction is not like oh it's all it's
all glamorous like they're really real
about it and I think that that narrative
is super important just because you hear
about all these challenges and mental
health issues for founders and CEOs and
being able to be honest and take about
the challenges it's just as important as
the wins absolutely
and the last question is about aliens
are you able to worry non-b I didn't
watch the most recent video the video
from like when was it like two weeks ago
I saw it I think the universe is too
large and vast for their to not be life
elsewhere
alright that's fair that the us Oh video
you'll appreciate that I tweeted it and
people started saying to me that's old
and I said what do you mean and they're
like oh it got leaked like years ago and
this was just them confirming that it
was real and so I was it wasn't you know
brand new but also that the internet be
you know the federal government to
releasing the videos but like what else
do you expect from you well yeah exactly
you're like no no sorry it was just
confirmation so yeah I will go back and
watch it now after this question so
they're sure what a one question do you
have for me to to wrap this up oh so i
one question would be how are you
thinking about crypto in this economic
downturn you were ever the optimist but
I would love to hear your take on where
we are I haven't actually looked into it
much given what I've been busy with the
last two months
so last June I started writing
macro-environment
some like very early alarm bells we're
starting to look weird and I said at
some point we will go into another
recessionary period I don't know exactly
when that is but but just naturally that
has to happen central banks have two
tools they'll manipulate the interest
rate down and they'll print money and I
remember writing about it almost
gleefully hoping that it would all
happen around the Bitcoin having right
and kind of like wouldn't it be
interesting if all of this happened
around the same time and that would
serve as kind of rocket fuel for the
growth of this deflationary asset we're
here they've done you know race to 0
faster than I
thought pop they've printed literally
trillions more than I thought I was
imaginable in the Bitcoin having
successfully executed earlier this week
and and so I think that when you put
those three events together I talked to
people both in the macro kind of Wall
Street world and also the crypto world I
just keep going back to this thing of
like supply and demand economics are
valid and if you print a lot of money
you devalue your currency like those are
two such simple concepts that I think
actually part of the problem with the
analysis of this type of stuff is people
overthink yeah they try to like get be
smarter than supply and demand economics
like how could it be that easy type
thing right right but I always tell
people that like because of that that's
where really the bullishness comes from
yeah you also have to understand like it
could be more complex and therefore it
could not work as well so it's so super
hard but for whatever reason I just
don't see you know supply and demand
economics and kind of the printing of
money not doing the things that we've
known they've done for literally
thousands so we'll see it's uh it's very
interesting and you know you're starting
to see more people who I think are like
the mainstream as Paul Tudor Jones said
in a recent note he said he's not a
crypto nut right was kind of how he put
it like we will start to do this I think
then you know it becomes easier less
career risk and we'll see how it plays
out
yeah yeah I love it well I look forward
to five you're my you're my crypto
expert so cuz everything I follow
do you accept Bitcoin thats what everyoe
yeah yeah we should we should we do not
yet I mean many many e-commerce
companies do so awesome where can we
send people to find out more about
Everly well and then find you
yeah so my Twitter although I'm on a bit
of a Twitter break just because of the
the work right now to get our to get our
company scaled to meet everybody's needs
is julia t cheek and then you can visit
more about everly well i really well
calm awesome jus listen I appreciate you
doing this I think people will learn a
lot and hopefully over there and check
out all the labs you guys have yeah
thanks so much it was great to see you